62 % des communes françaises sont
dépourvu de commerce et certains se
mobilisent pour conserver un dynamisme
économique souvenez-vous en début
d'année les habitants du petit village
d'abilli dans le sud Touren travaillit
dur pour rénover un ancien restaurant et
en faire un lieu multiservice
accueillant une épicerie un restaurant
et des chambres d'utes un projet à
736000 € hors taxe financé à 40 % par
l'État qui a pu voir le jour grâce à des
chantiers participatifs les travaux sont
désormais terminés et l'inauguration a
eu lieu aujourd'hui Lucas
Chopin un ruban coupé et beaucoup
d'émotion aujourd'hui à habillli la
commune a inauguré cet après-midi le
relais de Touren après 15 ans de
fermeture ce projet a vu le jour à
l'initiative de la nouvelle Gérande des
lieux je suis fière que le bâtiment
rouvre et espère vraiment que les gens
vont s'y sentir bien en fait au au-delà
du
commercial je veux que les gens viennent
parce que c'est un lieu et qui s'y sent
bien et cette convivialité s'est
vérifiée avant même l'ouverture de
nombreux citoyens ont participé à la
construction de ce tierslieu des
citoyens comme investi d'une mission et
que le maire n'a pas eu de mal à motiver
il y a pas eu besoin de les convaincre
ils sont complètement entrés dans le
dans le projet tout de suite avec les
premiers chantiers participatifs les
deuxè et le 3è et puis tout au long de
tout au long du projet ils ont toujours
été présents AB a toujours été réputé
pour être solidaire et unis et dynamique
donc bon ça n'a pas changé
fondamentalement les choses puisque on
l'était déjà mais ça a déclenché un
petit enthousiasme autour de ce projet
du relais de Touren oui l'État a apporté
une grande partie des fonds de ce projet
qui se présente comme un vecteur de
cohésion sociale dans une commune d'un
peu plus d'un millier d'âmes c'est un
projet très précurseur c'est un vrai
projet également de territoire puisque
il n'y a pas d'autres épicerie dans un
rayon de 8 km et il y avait une vraie
nécessité d'hébergement collectif dans
un rayon de 15 km ici sur ce territ toi
et donc je suis très heureux que à
travers ce projet que nous puissions
redonner de la vie à cette commune
d'abilli l'inauguration du relais de
Touren s'inscrit dans la continuité des
mesures initiées pour faire revivre
abilli une commune qui se montre ouverte
aux projets les plus
ambitieux